ben i think i'm paraphrasing here
something that you said but
to the effect that of the beauty of
cinema is showing a character that has
failed or has flaws and you said that as
a moviegoer this is what you love
about films why why does that intrigue
you yeah i mean
for me one of my all-time
favorite character in fiction would be
walter white that's i'm such a huge fan
of breaking bad and the great thing is
um he's not a bad guy
per se i mean he's making of course bad
decision and acts along the seri the
series
but i mean in the first two episodes you
understand who this guy
is and you understand that he wants to
leave he wants
to feel alive again and and that's why
i mean you can that's why this character
is has been taking all these viewers
with him
on these kind of crazy route uh
to the end of the show because people
were able to follow him
anywhere because we're all water white
and
we're all uh wanting to
get the life we want to feel alive
and i think that that's what i felt
uh with the character of dad playing by
matt cooper that i felt that
this guy wanted to be loved and wanted
to have a good living and
and of course his actions to get that
are
bad really bad but
where it comes from it's something that
is universal
and that's why people were are rolling
with uh
water white i mean i mean
the crazy thing is at the end of the
series you were
you're like oh he's been doing so many
bad stuff
and i think that we were not realizing
because we were
so much empathizing with him because of
what he's been through
and what he really wanted to have in
life the key thing for me is when
in the first season when he just he has
his big break with
the the drug dealer tuko i mean he's
like he's blowing the whole place
up and then he has his money and the car
is like yelling and he's he feels alive
and i think for me that's
the epicenter of what characters on
screen
should be and what i love to see about
them
so you wouldn't want to see like let's
suppose this this perfect guy
who's got the the supermodel wife and
drives this great sports car and
never gets mad and has this like perfect
zen
attitude it's not that's not appealing
well
actually that's that's pretty appealing
too i mean in a way
uh i think about the wolf of wall street
well it's not
it's not leonardo dicaprio is not that
then in the movie
uh but
i i love the way also this guy wants to
also feel alive and he has he's a is a
true bad guy but he uh it's so i mean
he's a wolf because
he he wants something which is visceral
and i think which has existed since dawn
of time
uh in human nature and so i think as
long as
screenwriters are able to make any
character
we it can be a loser or or
a multi-millionaire i mean
any character if the writer is able to
make us relate to him through a
something visceral i think it's it
should be something
visceral something we which is something
we
all aspire to have danged down then
then the par i mean the the the match is
is won i mean you have won as soon as
the audience can root for this guy and
because
they are feeling what this guy is
feeling
you